peace love and rock and roll it's the
hippie creed along with some flower
power and some crunchy granola and we
call hippies crunchy granola because of
well
granola
[Music]
the link between the people the culture
and the granola it started in 1969 at
woodstock
organizers estimated that 200 000
fun-loving people would build a small
town of bethlehem new york for the
three-day historic festival but the
number of attending doubled and the next
thing they knew there were over 400 000
people camping out which led to
shortages food shortages and well that
left the munchies craving free loving
hippies a little hangry
this is where the savior hugh romney
came in hugh and his commune hog farm
were hired to help organizers run the
festival upon seeing the food shortage
they stepped in to help they rounded up
a group of volunteers hit the streets
and came back with you guessed it
granola
members of hog farm filled tons of cups
and hugh took the stage and announced
there would be breakfast in bed for 400
000.
the hippies ate it up and for many it
was their first introduction to the
crunchy stuff and so there you have it
the original bond between crunchy
granola and hippies was formed by
granola at the one and only woodstock
music festival
[Music]
you